jo leute ich hatte schon lange vor euch
den inhalt dieses videos bzw
meine gedanken zu dem thema ich halt in
einem video mitzuteilen ein freund von
mir und zwar der dylan hat vor einiger
zeit ein video produziert das mich dazu
stark inspiriert hat und mich halt dazu
angeregt hat dieses video ähnlich zu
gestalten
das video ist einfach mal in der video
beschreibung verlinkt lohnt sich auf
jeden fall da mal vorbeizuschauen aber
erst das video schon natürlich also ich
würde sagen fangen wir an
zuerst kann ich sagen ich liebe mein
leben und ich bin froh dass es so ist
wie es ist allerdings habe ich oftmals
das gefühl dinge zu tun meistens dinge
die von der gesellschaft halt so
vorgeschrieben werden mit denen ich
kostbare zeit verschwende und ich bin
mir auch sicher damit stehe ich nicht
alleine da ich spiele einfach mal zwölf
jahre zurück damals war ich sechs und
war froh endlich in die schule zu kommen
ich meinen endlich erwachsen zu werden
lesen und schreiben zu lernen
hausaufgaben machen zu dürfen war damals
was cooles ihr wisst was ich meine ich
habe nichts hinterfragt und alles
einfach so hingenommen was will man auch
in der grundschule groß hinterfragen ich
habe das alles locker gemeistert und
durfte auch auf das gymnasium gehen ja
zumindest erstmal auch in der fünften
bis achten klasse bin ich einfach zur
schule gegangen weil das jeder so machte
meine eltern ist natürlich auch so
wollten und ich auch heute noch einen
guten abschluss haben möchte
doch irgendwann war ich dann so weit
über dinge nachzudenken und nicht
einfach alles so hinzunehmen mit 14 15
jahren hatte ich dann so eine phase wo
ich mir gedacht habe was mache ich hier
und wozu brauche ich das alles eine
andere wahl stand mir allerdings nicht
zur verfügung ich fing an über meine
schullaufbahn nachzudenken mit sechs
jahren kommt man in die schule klar gibt
es noten dann erst in der dritten klasse
aber die wird schon oft genug gesagt ob
du scheiße bist oder halt nicht
grundschule dann versucht kaum
entwickelten kinder nach leistung zu
unter tränen die da ist schlau die kommt
ans gymnasium der da ist schlecht
hauptschule so von bilden eigentlich
sorry aber was anderes als pervers
wirklich pervers fällt mir dazu nicht
ein ist doch auch klar was es mit zum
zehnjährigen macht indirekt gesagt zu
bekommen dass man noch nichts kann jetzt
bin ich grad in der zwölften klasse und
klar ist es wichtig in die schule zu
gehen
meiner meinung nach aber vor allem
deshalb um zu lernen miteinander
klarzukommen freunde zu finden sein
selbstbewusstsein aufzubauen meinetwegen
auch feine zu finden aber garantiert
nicht so wie es mir wirklich jeden tag
gesagt wird auf das leben vorbereitet zu
werden denn unter vorbereiten auf das
spätere leben verstehe ich nicht fächer
zu haben die mich langweilen für die ich
kein talent habt denn für dinge die
einen langweilen kann man auch gar kein
talent haben ich verstehe darunter
wirklich vorbereitet zu werden wissen
was ich mal machen möchte versicherungen
wohnungen und und ich kann das wirklich
so ausdrücken dass ich zurzeit schon
angst habe einfach nichts zu finden klar
mit youtube verdiene ich sicherlich
schon einiges für mein alter auch besser
als die meisten anderen die jetzt im
getränkemarkt oder so arbeiten nur noch
zur schule gehen eben ein aber was ist
bitte youtube es kann genauso schnell
vorbei sein wie es aber angefangen
das einzige was ich sagen kann ist dass
ich mal irgendwas mit medien machen
würde ich meinen da kenne ich mich aus
besser als die meisten anderen besser
als viele andere was genau das weiß ich
allerdings noch nicht woher auch
vielleicht ja aus meinem matte kurs da
reden wir gerade darüber wie
wahrscheinlich es ist dass beim würfeln
zweimal hintereinander der sechs kommt
und weiß jetzt ich würde wirklich keine
ausbildung machen ich weiß jetzt nicht
ob das irgendwie einen großen sinn macht
hier zu sagen hey wenn du jetzt
irgendwie eine ausbildung für mich hast
kann ja sogar sein also wenn irgendwer
von euch in nrw wohnt und sich denkt den
alex brauche ich in meiner medienagentur
oder sowas schreibt eine mail steht eine
video beschreibung
vielleicht bringt das der sogar
irgendwas ich weiß es nicht
leute das war's erst mal mit diesem
video ich hoffe es hat euch so ein
bisschen gefallen und was auch wirklich
ganz wichtig also könne natürlich erst
mal bewährt hinterlassen wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann daumen nach oben
hierfür wird mich echt freuen und
schreib doch mal eure meinung zu dem
ganzen die kommentare wie seht ihr das
stimmt ihr zu oder nicht also
würd mich stark interessieren ich löcher
war nicht durch und antwort und danke
auch an meinen netten kameramann heraus
kann sich mal kurz zeigen
checkt auch auf jeden fall mal seinen
kanal ab ist in der video beschreibung
und wir sind uns am nächsten dienstag
wieder ab so abonniert ihn abonnieren
mann